das sind wirklich große pläne und ein
einmaliges projekt europa will ab dem
jahr 2024 das größte erdgebundene
teleskope der welt betreiben und die
vorbereitungen dafür laufen auf
hochtouren mit dem extremely large
telescope e elt in den chilenischen
bergen stehen die chancen gut unser
wissen über das universum zu
revolutionieren unter anderem soll das
rt nach außerirdischem leben ausschau
halten wie das gigantische teleskop
genau aufgebaut wird was es
schlussendlich leisten wird und welche
spannenden ergebnisse sich die
forschungsteams erträumen
das alles und noch viel mehr jetzt den
klicks hensel fiction herzlich
willkommen ja und vielen dank für euren
themenvorschlag auf whatsapp dass et
wird das leistungsfähigste und
ehrgeizigste teleskop seiner art sein
das sagt der präsident der europäischen
südsternwarte des european southern
observatoriums oprah trikot auch bei der
grundsteinlegung des extremely large
telescope sell r im vergangenen jahr im
mai 2017 unter generaldirektor tim den
zwölf ergänzt der sprung von den
gegenwärtigen teleskopen zum lte ist
etwa so groß wie der sprung von galli
virus auge zu seinem teleskop das et
führt also in eine neue ära der
astronomie und das in gewaltigen
dimensionen der hauptspiegel des
teleskops wird fünf mal größer sein und
dadurch 13 mal mehr licht anfangen
können als es bei den derzeit besten
teleskope möglich ist dass ist eine
garantie für sehr viele schärfere bilder
im vergleich zum weltraumteleskop hubble
wird es wohl 16 mal kleinere details
erkennbar machen und es geht weiter
allein sein gewaltiger drehbarer kuppel
aufbau mit einem durchmesser von 85
metern ist von der größe her
vergleichbar mit der fläche eines
fußballfeldes das lte soll vor allem
exoplaneten unter die lupe nehmen denn
dort könnte es bislang unentdecktes
leben geben wir berichten ja immer
wieder davon
die planetenforschung weltweit über
bietet sich derzeit darin den ersten
bewohnbaren exo planeten aufzuspüren
aber auch supermassereiche schwarze
löcher und die rätsel um die verteilung
der dunklen materie und der dunklen
energie könnten mit dem gigantischen
teleskop gelöst werden ein besonderes
augenmerk soll auch auf der
frühgeschichte und der zukunft des
universums liegen und das müsst ihr euch
mal vorstellen von den etwa 2005
astrophysikern und astrophysikerin in
deutschland werden wohl zwei drittel mit
den daten des lte arbeiten im
vergangenen jahr im mai 2017 wurde in
mainz der sekundär spiegel aus
glaskeramik gegossen
das war der erste meilenstein in dem
wirklich aufwändigen
herstellungsprozesses lte etwa ein jahr
hat sein abkühlung prozess gedauert und
jetzt wird er noch in frankreich
geschliffen und poliert sein durchmesser
beträgt wahnsinnige vier meter und sein
gewicht 3,5 tonnen
somit ist er der größte sekundär spiegel
eines teleskops weltweit und zudem der
grösste konvexe spiegel der menschheit
er wird kopfüber dem hauptspiegel
aufgehängt seine aufgabe wird darin
bestehen dass von vom riesigen
hauptspiegel eingefangene licht über
weitere spiegel hin zu den
messinstrumenten zu leiten aber auch der
hauptspiegel ist nicht ohne denn um
diese leistungsfähigkeit zu erreichen
sind rekordleistung nötig in besteht aus
knapp 800 einzelnen 66 spiegeln die
beweglich sind und sich die spiegel form
so bei jeder temperatur und der neigung
des teleskops optimal anpassen kann
konkret wird das egt auf einem
abgelegenen berggipfel in chiles atacama
wüste zu hause sein
da war ich auch schon mal da ist es sehr
hoch und sehr trocken
der amazonas berg ist und 3000 meter
hoch und vor zwei jahren wurde seine
spitze gesprengt um eine plattform für
das mega teleskop errichten zu können
hier in der atacama-wüste betreibt die
eso teleskop an drei standorten unter
anderem auch das very large telescope
vlt das besteht aus vier teleskopen die
sich miteinander kombinieren lassen so
könnte eine ein euro münze aus einer
entfernung von 5000 kilometern erkannt
werden und die bedingungen in dieser
region sind für astronomische studium
besonders geeignet denn größere städte
mit störenden lichtquellen die sind weit
entfernt zudem ist die luft klar und
trocken und die sogenannte humboldt
strömung sorgt dafür dass die region
meist komplett wolkenfrei ist optimale
bedingungen also für wissenschaftliche
sternenbeobachtung auch wenn es ein
wenig kurios klingt von dieser
abgelegenen ecke der erde lebenszeichen
im weltall zu finden das erp projekt
läuft seit 2012 ende 2014 wurde sein bau
genehmigt zehn jahre später also 2024
wird das mega teleskop dann wohl
erstmalig an den start gehen dahinter
steckt wie gesagt die europäische
die sternwarte die im oktober 1962 durch
deutschland belgien frankreich schweden
und den niederlanden gegründet wurde
mittlerweile gehört sie mit zu den
erfolgreichsten forschungseinrichtungen
europas derzeit hat sie 15
mitgliedsstaaten die finanziell
technisch und wissenschaftlich zum
projekt beitragen deutschland ist das
größte aller mitglieder und steuert 230
millionen euro von den baukosten dazu
insgesamt sieht es nach kosten von 1,1
milliarden euro aus und wir haben hier
auch großes vor klicks um werbefrei zu
machen nämlich nämlich immer wenn wir
entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder
gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung
vor einem monatlichen video ab werdet
also mitglied hier unter dem video
draufklicken oder auf den linken der
video beschreibung für einen kleinen
beitrag bekommt den dazu noch einige
extras und wenn er immer garantiert über
aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt
dann hättet mich übrigens bei whatsapp
dann bekommt ihr den link zum aktuellen
video vor allen anderen von mir
persönlich auf euer handy einfach hier
draufklicken und darunter geht es weiter
mit
dafür auch draufklicken natürlich hast
du ihn bedrohen die erde jederzeit und
das ist wirklich der fall also bis dann
bleibt dran